اعلن الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان التي
اتفاقيه نقل الحبوب الاوكرانيه مددت لمده
100 و20 يوما اعتبارا من التاسعه عشر من
شهر نوفمبر 20 الثاني الحلي كنتيجه
للمحادثات التي استضافتها بلادها صرح
اردوغان اذا في سلسله تغريدات على تويتر
انا اهميه هذه الاتفاقيه ظهرت بوضوح
وتبينت فائدتها بالنسبه للامدادات
الغذائيه والامن الغذائي في العالم واوضح
ان اكثر من 11 مليون طن من الحبوب سلمت
الى دول الفقيره عبر نحو 500 سفينه في
الاشهر الاربعه الماضيه شكرا يا رئيس تركي
كل من الامين العام للامم المتحده
والرئيسين
والاكرانيه على الاراده التي يظهروها
لتمديد الاتفاقيه مهنئا كل من كان له
اسهاما في تحقيقه هذا الهدف
ينضم الينا شبكه مراسلين من كييف معنا
مراسل الجزيره المعتز بالله حسن من
اسطنبول لمراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج ومن
موسكو معنى مراسله الجزيره سلام خضر مرحبا
بكم جميعا وسنبدا من اسطنبول عمر الحاج
كيف يجري التعامل مع هذا الانجاز انه
الاجازه وصفه بذلك بتمديد اتفاقيه تصدير
الحبوب من خلال تركيا
نعم ميسي لابد من القول ان هناك نوع من
الارتياح التركي هنا في الاوساط السياسيه
التركيه بعد تمكن الاطراف جميعا من
الاتفاق على تمديد هذا الاتفاق لاربعه
شهور اضافيه الرئيس اردوغان اعلن عن ما
سماه هذا النجاح وان هن كل الاطراف على
نيتهم الجديه في عدم الاخلال بهذا الاتفاق
الذي بدا ببساطه تركيه وايضا برعايه
الامميه في الثانيه والعشرين من شهر تموز
المنصرم والذي تمكنت من خلاله اوكرانيا من
استئنا في تصدير حبوب الرئيس اردوغان
حقيقه في تصريحات سابقه له قال انه لا يجد
من المناسب بان تقوم روسيا بايقاف تصدير
الحبوب ايقاف العمل بهذه الاتفاق وذلك ردا
على بعض التصريحات الروسيه وخاصه من رئيس
البوت الذي قال ان تركيا ان روسيا تفكر
في هذه الصادرات لانها لا تلبي احتياجاتها
وان روسيا ليست للمست اكبر من هذه
الاتفاقيه كما ذكرنا الرئيس اردوغان قال
ان هناك اكثر من 500 سفينه وصلت الى
وجهتها وان تركيا وبمساعده الاطراف جميعا
تمكنت من الحد من ازمه الغذاء العالمي
وانه يطمح في الاستمرار استمرار العمل
بهذه الاتفاقيه كما هو كما هي الاليه
المعتاده فستمر السفن التركيه
بالتواجد في همم بالتوقع في البحر الاسود
اضافه الى عمليات عذرا الوصول الى الموانئ
التركيه وبعد ذلك الى الوجهات التي يتفق
عليها كلا الجانبين ايضا كان هناك همم
حديث سابق للرئيس اردوغان قال ان همم انه
يؤكد او ربما يتفق مع الرئيس بوت الذي قال
في وقت سابق الذي اتفاقيه الحبوب التي كان
اول اهدافها وصول هذه الشحنات الى البلدان
الفقيره لم تحقق هذا الهدف بدليل ان جل
الشحنات ذهبت الى دول اوروبا وايضا دول
ليست في حاجه ماسه مع دول افريقيا ودول
اخرى وبالتالي ربما هناك مسعد تركي الان
لضمان لتحقيق هذه الغايه اضافه الى ضمان
تحقيق المنافع على الروسيه التي تقضي
باستئناف تصدير الحبوب الروسيه وايضا
شحنات الاسمده والاسهم والمواد الزراعيه
التي كانت روسيا تصدرها قبل اندلاع الحرب
مع اوكرانيا